i was cooking i don't cooking or any
manual labor
yeah i i've never dreamt about half of
my dreams are just that
just doing chores around the house just
cleaning up after you and every time i
look back there's more dirt
yeah then i realized oh this isn't a
dream this is my real life
yeah you're just awake you should never
be a fantasy
writer oh you want a [ __ ] bet [ __ ]
i mean you're dr well i don't know why
you're getting so aggressive i just
i'm ass telling i have fantasies
i know i have big large sexual fantasies
just based on your dreams though you
have sexual fantasies oh my god
no i'm not a fantasy when it comes to
like strictly like
you know developing creatures and like
dune
or you know lord of the rings right or
just uh
you know um prophecy and creating a
prophecy and creating
i think underestimate me because number
one i'm very philosophical
number two i'm very science-minded so
tiny things
like i could probably write a good
oh you're right maybe not fantasy all
right i'm gonna ask you right now i'm
gonna ask you something right now right
yeah create a creature
with with ford create a creature with
four animal parts right okay and some
sort of weird power go
okay so do it go
or don't think this particular creature
no you're right now you're killing time
well right now i'm thinking
aquaman is aquaman right but deep deep
down there's a man called the angler
and what the angler has is he has a
little bit of um like a
um another creature attached to him yes
that has then
merged and now he has a power of one and
a half
mutants right because they call him the
angler and on top of that he has
he's tricking us in the depths of the
ocean he has this thing that protrudes
out of his
head like like an orb that lights his
way
so that's what gives him the superpower
is that no one else can see their
surroundings but him
right right yeah yeah so you want four
body parts
so he has the melon right he has the
melon and the intelligence of an orca
which is smarter than all right you you
proved your point
that's the inspiration you proved your
point all right i cheated though because
i know a lot about sea creatures
yeah this creature i think at the angler
i think i
that's where i [ __ ] up everything can
i give you one more super power yeah
okay so the the the angler man right
when he is agitated he releases this
thing
like this super slime that's similar to
that of a hagfish
babe angler man i mean kids aren't kind
of like you want
be excited to see the angler man hagfish
slime kids love slime
imagine angle man just slopping his way
onto the beach
people just running in terror or at
disney it's like oh black panther an
angler fan he has one half of a mutant
attack
yeah give me a chance um um marvel like
let me pitch
yeah huh well you do have fantasy babe
that's my bad i have a lot of fantasy
what was sci-fi go ahead
could you get could you picture a sci-fi
movie like matrix what would you say in
a studio like a christopher nolan film
give me something philosophical and
weird how about you
let's go let's go sci-fi movie you go
we'll go back and forth i'll go
step-by-step
so there there's an m-class planet okay
i don't know what that means
it's because you played this [ __ ] in
that one no no no no no no no no no no
no what's in your video game
it's a it's a it's a planet that like
can um
much like our planet it has a you know
we have
um an atmosphere oxygen you know i mean
and
life can live on it